[Musique]
le plus économique un radiateur
ici le 14 degrés qu'on a en général dans
la maison ne pose plus de problème de
façon générale sauf de temps en temps et
à ce moment-là on a on a une capacité
d'action
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que les bureaux vous le
voyez sont parfois relativement vides
ici le seul bureau occupé est celui-ci
donc je vais venir chauffer toute cette
grande pièce juste pour moi ça n'a
parfois pas beaucoup de sens et ça
consomme beaucoup d'énergie donc en fait
on peut venir chauffer uniquement le la
personne mon corps en l'occurrence ou
une petite bulle de chaleur au niveau du
bureau
[Musique]
mots après la température plus fraîche
et on voit que ça a été tout à fait
confortable pour les premiers hivers
nous ont permis de voir qu'on pouvait
descendre facilement de trois quatre
degrés sans perdre pour autant en
confort et qu'il existe des solutions
d'appoint une fois qu'on a trouvé notre
seuil de confort qui permettent de se
réchauffer localement en dépensant
beaucoup moins d'énergie qu'avec le
chauffage central
donc il y a des questions d'habitude qui
sont à la fois physiologiques et mentale
je pense et qui font que on supporte des
choses qu'on imaginait pas supporter
avant mais il faut y aller
progressivement chacun à son rythme il y
a pas de recette universelle
[Musique]